друзья Добрый день Сегодня я хотел бы с
вами поговорить об очень важном элементе
казинопланирования это кластеризация
времени
в технологии казнь планирования очень
много фишек но я сегодня Вам расскажу
Только о кластеризации времени
кластеризация Времени очень сильный И
важный инструмент
учеными многочисленные за счет
многочисленных исследований доказано что
переключение между задачами отнимает от
25 до 30 процентов вашей эффективности
Вы наверное сами не раз замечали когда
вы проводите какую-то встречу или
какую-то задачу делаете например читаете
отчет а потом вас прерывают а потом
чтобы вернуться в отчет вам придется
опять все заново прочитать переосмыслить
и так далее каждый раз любое
переключение вашего внимания съедает
25-30 процентов времени только на то
чтобы въехать опять в то о чем вы до
этого говорили или чем вы до этого
занимались поэтому
кластеризация Просто внедряя этот
инструмент вы на 25-30 процентов
повышаете свою эффективность просто
сходу и это я вам говорю только об одной
части кластеризации то есть об одном
эффекте второе эффект Давайте еще раз
напомню кластеризация снимает
проблемы с переключением между задачами
И тем самым на 25-30 процентов
увеличивает вашу эффективность второе
очень важный эффект второй очень важный
эффект кластеризации это то что многие
например
планируют что-то
какой-то ставит какие-то цели но не
отводят под это ресурс а Конкретно если
говорить ресурс времени
кластеризация как раз таки решает этот
вопрос кластеризация это такие блоки
времени которые блокируют вы для
определенных задач всем наверное
известна такая паутинка или Балан колесо
в вашей жизни где вы многие планируют
себе Уделять больше внимания семье
работе хобби общественным делам и так
далее но к сожалению у многих на уровне
вот этой цели или колеса баланса все и
остается колесо баланса само по себе не
может себя достигнуть Вы должны это сами
достигать Но как это делается это
достигается за счет выделения ресурса
времени Под каждый Аспект вашей жизни
так вот кластеризация вам поможет
достигать баланс вашей жизни
автоматически
дальше очень важный момент в течение дня
многие бизнесмены очень часто
выполняют дела не в правильном
приоритете например многие говорят что
надо выполнять сначала важные дела А
некоторые говорят что нужно сначала там
сесть лягушку или неприятные дела и так
далее так вот я вам скажу
вам нужно выполнять важные дела самые
продуктивное для Вас время самое
эффективное для Вас время если это
касательно мыслительного процесса то
лучше всего это делать не сразу после
пробуждения а чуть позже но никак не
после обеда Поэтому каждому занятию
нужно отводить оптимально для этого
занятия время и вот в этом Вам сильно
поможет кластеризация как теперь
работает кластеризация Я планирую таким
образом вот представьте себе
Вот время
12 часов 6
3 9 часов
так вот я каждый день
разбиваю кстати сразу еще хочу сказать
одну фишку кластеризации это то что
многие предприниматели еще делят или
планируют только работу я же
рассматриваю работу и отдых Как одну
единицу Как одна единица планирования
например Когда я планирую работу я у
меня стандартное время для под любую
задачу это 45 минут я отвожу так вот я
отвожу в планирование отвожу не 45 минут
я тоже час я всегда планировал 45
минутную задачу 15-минутный отдых То
есть у меня нету отдельного отдыха
отдельно работы я рассматриваю одна
Плановая единица одна Плановая единица у
меня как правило 45 минут задачи 15
минут отдыха Поэтому вот это очень важно
отдых автоматически должен следовать
вместе с работой так вот как я
кластеризирую свой день у меня часов
подъем
и до 10 часов утра
то 10 часов утра
Это мое личное время
Это мое личное время я утром встаю в это
время никто не может мне мешать я сижу у
себя в кабинете я просматриваю во-первых
что во-первых у меня утром здесь
гигиенические процедуры Понятно иногда
бывает так что я утром хожу потом у меня
уходит время Час планирования Я каждое
утро пересматриваю свои планы
пересматриваю свои цели проверяю до сих
пор актуально ли эти цели для меня
потому что Хуже всего Когда вы
эффективно занимаетесь тем чем не нужно
заниматься А это бывает в том случае
Когда цель для вас уже не актуальна А вы
продолжаете ее преследовать поэтому так
как я использую систему динамического
планирования Если вы хотите больше
узнать различных системах планирования
то можете посмотреть позже у меня на
курсе основы личной эффективности так
вот Согласно вот этой системе
динамического планирования Я каждое утро
реактуализирую или делаю ревизию своих
целей и своих планов дальше у меня
Кайден час Кайден час это специальный
час отведенный для того чтобы заниматься
оптимизацией автоматизацией своей
деятельности То есть это как вот если я
лесоруб рубил лес то у меня час времени
уходит на заточку топора вот кайзен чат
это час посвященный оптимизации моей
работы моей деятельности дальше я я
смотрю новости мессенджеры я читаю я
составляю график текущего дня то есть
готовлюсь к Дню вот у меня на это уходит
4 часа времени это называю я называю
личное время
время
таким образом эти четыре часа я посвящаю
только себе
дальше
с 10 часов до часу дня
до 13:00
у меня это время посвящено работе
это время у меня посвящено работе и в
это время я читаю отчеты я читаю
аналитику я провожу совещание я
встречаюсь с ключевыми сотрудниками и
так далее там я пишу курсы например в
это время это время полностью посвящено
работе причем это время я вывел здесь не
случайно это самое эффективное время для
принятия решений в основном я здесь
занимаюсь принятием решений и сложными
аналитическими задачами такие как отчеты
написание курсов какие-то совещания и
так далее
поэтому под Вот это дело я выделил под
эти дела я выделил самое я называю
прайм-тайм самое лучшее время когда я
энергичен и когда мой мозг работает на
максимальной эффективности
дальше
двух часов
до 18 часов
у меня время общественное
здесь я назову работа
здесь я назову общество
или общение можно
а с двух часов до 18 часов в это время я
провожу все свои встречи все свои зумы
там все встречи по общественным делам
обсуждения и так далее То есть вот это
время полностью посвящено взаимодействию
с другими людьми почему это важно потому
что в это время снижается Мозговая
активность и в то же время в это время
вы наиболее расслаблены не напряжены вам
легко общаться Вы спокойно общаетесь у
вас
хороший Темп общения
в таком благодушном расслабленном
состоянии
И поэтому это так в это время вы не
принимаете критически важных решений
соответственно здесь ничего страшного
это время не приходится на ответственные
решения все ответственные решения у меня
принимается вот здесь Таким образом у
меня закрывается третье направление
видите личные работа общение далее
с 18:00 до 9:30
у меня здесь
семья
друзья
с 18:00 до 9:30 это время которое я
посвящаю семье семейным делам друзьям в
это время мы общаемся смотрим кино
вместе ужинаем Ну это все время
посвященное либо друзьям обычно пару раз
в неделю все остальное время это время
посвященное семейным делам таким образом
вы видите что вечером как раз самое
спокойное время когда не надо Нет
большой суеты когда надо готовиться ко
сну в это время вы ведете как бы
спокойные беседы в семье с членами своей
семьи и так далее в это время дети
приходят уже со школой все пришли с
работы никто ничем не занят такой
неспешное время самое хорошее время Либо
вместе что-то почитать Либо вместе
посмотреть какой-то фильм Либо вместе
поужинать таким образом вы видите что
кластеризация
охватывает первое
это личное время второе работу
третье это общественные дела и четвертое
это семья и пятое это друзья и вы видите
что кластеризация времени либо Вот это
колесо баланса которое многие преследуют
оно автоматически вшито у меня в
распорядок дня Почему кластеризация дня
еще важна вот смотрите Бывает такая
ситуация что мне звонят или пишут после
беды и назначают встречу говорит можем
встретиться смотрите Я никогда не
позволяю одно время заехать на
территорию другого если кто-то против
встречи в 5:30 то я понимаю что встреча
будет литься полчаса 45 минут И еще у
меня 30 минут Будет уходить на работу на
дорогу поэтому я переношу встречу на
завтра либо отменяю встречу либо на
завтра я не позволяю
заехать этому времени суда плюс
реализация еще помогает тем что когда я
назначаю в городе встречи я их кучкую и
встречи я провожу тоже кластерами потому
что каждый выезд в город у меня полчаса
в город полчаса обратно У меня час
каждая встреча занимает час времени на
дорогу поэтому я кластеризирую время
таким образом чтобы после обеда провести
все встречи вот здесь выехал здесь
приехал в результате
Я всегда стремлюсь сделать таким образом
чтобы на час потраченного времени на
дорогу я провел как минимум 3 часа
встречи в городе Поэтому вот
кластеризация вам помогает еще в этом а
смотрите кластеризация выстраивает еще
раз подчеркну кластеризация
выстраивает колесо баланса вашей жизни в
автоматическом режиме первое второе
кластеризация делать Так что вы
выполняете каждый тип работы в самое
лучшее для этой работы время Ну работы
или задач время третья кластеризация
минимизирует переключение между
разнотипными задачами вы всё время
выполняете однотипные задачи там утром
например Это принять решение аналитика
отчёты и так далее после обеда только
общение вечером общение а утром
аналитика рефлексии и так далее дальше
кластеризация автоматически выстраивает
вам приоритеты и не позволяет одним
задачам из этого блока времени
переезжать А и съедать время от другого
блока
и вы таким образом а-а в течение дня
очень продуктивный
И самое главное еще кластеризация
помогает планировать режим работы и
отдыха Это то что касается кластеризации
дня у меня также есть кластеризация
недели кластеризация месяца и
кластеризация года но вкратце чтобы
долго не рассказывать скажу так вот
основа это год Когда я планирую год
сначала я беру календарь года и туда
заношу все личные дела Куда я хотел бы
поехать в какие-то там поездки выставки
зарубежные и так далее наношу сначала
личные дела потом на этот же календарь
начинает заносить все семейные дела
потом я начинаю доносить туда все что
связано с работой работы рабочие дела И
уже на оставшиеся время я планирую все
остальное поэтому
также год кластеризируйте себе год
самого начала это помогает вам тем что
это не столько план сколько представьте
себе на календаре вы просто букируете
или блокируете дни которые вы отвозите
там под отпуск под семейный отпуск либо
личная поездку и так далее Это еще не
точный план это еще не точные даты вы
примерно блокируете эти дни и это
помогает в чем в том что в течение
месяца что вы в спешке не заехали на
территорию вашей ваших запланированных
каких-то событий у вас эти дни они как
бы заблокированы вы можете планировать
только на те дни которые свободны таким
образом
обязательно занимайтесь кластеризацией и
очень важно всегда помнить Когда вы
делаете кластеризацию года и вы в первую
очередь занесли личные поездки потом
семейные события и поездки потом бизнес
вы Точно будете уверены что точно
закрыты все ваши личные дела Точно
закрыты ваши Семей и
все что сложно связано с вашей работой
обязательно Потом указывайте три главных
целей года в каждый месяц указывайте три
главных цели месяца
каждую неделю указывайте как минимум
одну главную цель недели и каждое утро
Оставьте себе цель выполнить одно
главное большое дело поэтому
кластеризация самого себя важна Но
помимо этого еще всегда в фокусе держите
все ваши цели на этом
аквастеризации я вкратце рассказал Все
если вам интересна эта тема то можете
потом записаться на мой курс основы
личной эффективности где мы будем
говорить о большом спектре инструментов
которые могут повысить вашу личную
эффективность и помогут вам достичь всех
ваших целей и решить все ваши проблемы
Спасибо